[Music]
the next time you go hiking near Red
Rock Canyon keep in mind there has been
a string of recent car break-ins Brian
will visited today to find out what
people can do to keep their belongings
safe
I was
literally shocked that they're coming
you know breaking into cars out here I
think it's targeting to us a string of
recent break-ins has struck the Red Rock
area with many reports on social media
of people losing their wallet purse or
tools from their vehicles that's what
they do is Scout the cars to see if they
see anything valuable and then
bust out your windows and take it people
I talk to are thinking about how to
protect themselves the one thing you can
do is think about how you can prevent a
break-in and if you have any belongings
can you hide them in the car so they're
not visible not enticing somebody to
look at and of course keep your car
locked to ensure you don't become a
victim of a vehicle break-in remember
these three tips lock your vehicle when
you leave
hide anything that's in your vehicle and
take your valuables with you John washco
is visiting from Cleveland he's a former
police officer he says it's unfortunate
for this to happen in such a beautiful
place like Red Rock when you're
victimized whether it's a violent crime
or something like this you still carry
that feeling you know of some criminal
that violated your car your house
whatever it is
and it's just a terrible feeling despite
the recent reports it's not deterring
these tourists from visiting the area
it's absolutely amazing I haven't seen
anything like this Brian will eight news
now
now if your car has been broken into
around the Red Rock area please report
it to the Bureau of Land Management and
you can find that information on our
website at 8newsnow.com